coriolan et une pièce bouleversante de
shakespeare dont la mise en scène de
robert lepage est renversante et très
grisante pour ses interprètes comme la
drogue c'est à dire que tout ce qu'on
fait potentiellement dangereux parce que
beaucoup technique la technologie
l'espace de jeu et reptiles et tout ça
est très extrêmes très enivrante dans
cette allégorie politique rythme et on
suit coriolan un chef de guerre romain
qui méprise son peuple au point de se
retourner contre lui s'il déteste son
peuple il aime beaucoup sa mère c'est
très freudien en effet le titre complexe
de digues qui est carrément pas réglé
que rihanna devrait aller consulter on
va se le dire
cette mère qui vit par et pour son fils
est jouée par anne marie cadieux
elle avait déjà camper ce rôle il ya 25
ans dans une version différente aussi
signé par robert lepage
robert c'est une pièce qu'ils fascinent
qu'il s'est parfois que la rondelle
avait déjà monté avant sauce donc une
connaissance très très très très
précises de cette pièce l'appui
évidemment l'eau des moyens il ya des
moyens exceptionnels c'est quand même
une production de machines
avec sa machine à idées robert lepage a
fait le pari de transposer la romantique
au monde d'aujourd'hui
l' approche scénique se rapproche
beaucoup du cinéma 3d avec ses
projections
ces nombreux fondu au noir et ses trente
et un changement de décor au vu des
changements que ce mec c'est ciment rap
et de genêts manqué une clôture en
général ce coriolan de robert lepage a
d'abord triomphé pendant cinq mois au
prestigieux festival de stratford en
ontario dans sa version en anglais
la production dispose de moyens qu'on
voit rarement théâtre avec ses 18
comédiens cessa vieux zh
ces 14 techniciens en coulisses et son
budget deux fois plus élevé que celui
normalement alloués aux autres pièce
présentée au tnm
pourquoi on peut se permettre coriolan
qui est dans le mandat de notre théâtre
les grands classé qui demande des grands
moyens
c'est vraiment la participation du
festival de stratford avant même la
grande première la pièce affiche presque
complet et avec raison le coriolan de
robert lepage est un événement théâtral
comme on en voit trop rarement ici
louis-philippe une radio canada montréal
[Musique]